welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and one of my
biggest questions after seeing love and
thunder is about that post-credits scene
you know where daddy zeus swears
vengeance on thor for stabbing him and
ruining his orgy but what are zeus's
plans to get back at the god of thunder
who besides hercules will aid in his
attempt to teach thor and new asgard a
lesson in respecting your horny
shirtless elders and how exactly will
this plot tie in with the future of the
mcu in the post-credits scene zeus tells
his zeus and his son hercules quote they
beg for your mercy without them knowing
if you're actually listening now when
they look to the sky they don't ask us
for lightning they don't ask for rain
they just want to see one of their
so-called superheroes when did we become
the joke no no more they will fear us
again when thor odinson falls from the
sky clearly the surface level
implication here is that zeus is
embarrassed by being shown up by thor to
roughly quote the khan's favorite rock
star bon jovi shut through the heart and
those two blame he gives gods a bad name
so to sue this fragile olympian ego zeus
is sending hercules out on a quest to
publicly humiliate thor and his
superhero friends in front of mortals to
re-establish the gods as beings to be
feared and worshipped although he didn't
get much more from the mcu's hercules
than a classic extremely rough roy kent
responds to daddy zeus's plan to pick up
where gore left off we do know a lot
about his character from the comics back
in 1986's journey into mystery annual
number one thor and hercules met when
thor crashed through the entrance to
olympus and started wrestling with the
son of zeus many of thor and herc's
early storylines depicted the two of
them brawling for panels upon panels
mostly to showcase the fact that their
strengths and powers were so equally
matched not only were they equally
powerful but they also each wielded
their own signature weapon thor's hammer
and hercules golden mace based on what
we saw in the post-credits scene we'll
definitely see these two go head-to-head
with their respective tools of battle
and match muscles when they return to
the mcu now obviously herc's a hero so
it should be expected that the two will
eventually earn a mutual respect for one
another and join forces to stop an
actual pressing threat a threat that'll
likely scare zeus or hercules into
putting aside their vendetta just like
thor fighting tony in the first avengers
this drama between thor and herc is only
a prelude to a bromance and possibly a
new super team personally i don't see
zoo simply sending hercules after thor
on his lonesome after duking it out with
the god of thunder zeus is going to need
more than just a half mortal son after
all if gore the god butcher couldn't
take thor down with his necro sword zeus
is going to need bigger guns than the
ones attached to hercules in order to
eliminate thor some sort of suicide
squad if you will interestingly in the
comics there's actually a divine team up
known as the god squad thor himself is
part of this roster along with hercules
who leads the team this group was
originally formed to fight the skrull
gods puppeteering the events of secret
invasion as we know the mcu's version of
secret invasion featuring sam jackson's
nick fury will be coming soon-ish to
disney plus as a six-part series this is
where i believe the connective tissue
between zeus's orders in love and
thunder's post-credits scene and the
grander mcu road map connects now i'm
not saying that secret invasion will
focus on or even have cameos of thor and
her as it looks to primarily be a spy
thriller about an infiltration from an
evil sect of skrulls on earth but i do
think that the event will have some
cosmic implications that will start to
tie everything together those
implications have to do with the big g
word no not gods galactus someone who
even zeus would fear we've long
suspected that galactus might be the
mcu's next thanos level threat and this
villain absolutely ties into the comic's
secret invasion galactus destroyed the
squirrel's home world tarnox iv which
combined with their grudge against earth
superheroes propelled them to finally
infiltrate our planet this invasion was
orchestrated by the skrull gods the
deities that herc's god squad was formed
to defeat although the mcu offers a
different backstory for the skrulls
their homeworld skrellows was destroyed
by the genocidal cree and the survivors
are just trying to find their own little
slice of new asgard it would make sense
to use 2023's the marvels or secret
invasion to introduce the concept of
galactus clearly the mcu's galactus
might not be responsible for taking the
scrolls home but his cosmic energy
sucking might be affecting their ability
to find a new one i do think that if
they use either of these properties to
introduce galactus it'll be a cameo a
quick line or a post-credits scene
similar to the way that they tease
thanos in small doses pre-infinity war
in my opinion this would be a great way
for thor and hercules to end up becoming
buddies although herc could initially be
in the game to do his daddy's bidding
perhaps the upcoming events of the
marvels or secret invasion will bring
these two together in friendship just
like how they're on again off again
friends throughout the comics so if zeus
does form a team of divine beings led by
hercules to beat up thor and the events
of secret invasion are about to
influence the mcu possibly leading
towards the galactus event who could be
joining this god squad ra the egyptian
sun god is first on my list of
candidates because he was also first on
thor's short list of gods to team up
with when he landed in omnipotent city
raw was also suspiciously mia during
moon night and he could be a bridge to
bring khanshu and moon knight into the
films in irl egyptian mythology amun raz
the god of sun and light and one of the
most important deities thor's other
calls are also on the table tuma tuwanga
the maori god of war and quetzalcoatl
the aztec god of wind sun air and
learning in a perfect world i'd also
love to see a member or two from the
comics god squad added to the mcu like
snowbird and amatsu mikabashi snow bird
also known as naria is the daughter of
nilvana inuit goddess of the northern
lights and a mortal father she can
transform into any animal native to
northern canada and can also fly heal
and see into the past then we have a
matsu mikaebashi the japanese god of
chaos evil and the stars in the comics
based on a shinto god of the same name
from japanese mythology this would be a
very interesting pick for zeus's hit
team because although he technically
helped defeat nightmare in the skrull
gods and secret invasion he's still an
antagonist for hercules and thor in the
comics it would be very cool to see him
pop up in the mcu as an agent of chaos
honorable mention of course goes to bow
the god of dumplings because if anyone
could teach thor a lesson he'll never
forget it's this fearsome deity these
are just some of my predictions for who
could end up on zeus's crew but i wanna
know what you guys think in the comments
follow me on instagram and twitter
whitneypuppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you